she will not stop she will escalate
until
you kill her or she kills you
maybe you're wrong simone the serum
never corrupted steve
touche but there has never been another
steve rogers has there
what's up everybody episode 4 of the
falcon and the winter soldier continues
to explore the ideas of power
responsibility and the question of what
truly makes someone a hero
or a villain also sorry folks zemo does
not dance
in this one consider this your spoiler
warning i'm carlos gustavonte and this
is e.t can libsner
[Music]
the episode begins with a flashback to
wakanda six years ago
where we see how io helped bucky
overcome his winter soldier programming
you're free
[Music]
in the present day however things are
not so sunny between the two
as bucky's been hanging out with the guy
who killed the king of wakanda back in
the day
and understandably i was not really
happening
guys
and we come for him that end of course
is getting to carly morgenthau and flag
smashers
the guys find out carly bombed the grc
supply depot killing three people in the
process
the timeline jumps up a little bit they
can't agree on what to do with carly
when they find her
even though she's dangerous sam believes
that she is helping people
and that maybe he can get through her
they go to the displaced person's camp
to ask about their one lead
donya madani a local hero she helped
carly and so many others displaced from
the blip before her passing
of course the people of the camp don't
trust outsiders and no one wants to
speak to them could it be because sam is
just walking around yelling
excuse me at people i don't know just
saying
i know who you are but i can't trust you
i'm sorry let's go zemo on the other
hand takes a sweeter tactic
literally giving children turkish
delight in exchange for information
didn't anyone tell these kids not to
take candy from super villains
well anyway it works the kids tell them
where and when donya's funeral will be
but if information zemo does not want to
share with sam and bucky unless they
drop them once they get what they need
stuck at a bit of a dead end what should
sam do but call in
another favor from sharon carter sharon
listen
i know i owe you already but we could
use the trustworthy set of eyes
on the camp you got any more tricks in
your bag i may or may not have access to
a satellite or two let me see what i can
do she also warns them that the power
broker is pissed that they killed
wilfred nagel
and it seems like this that they're
making that sharon is actually the power
broker thing
seem more and more likely i mean unless
episode 5 actually revealed it's
evan peters who's the power broker which
would be weird but
i wouldn't totally hate it meanwhile
carly and nico get more super soldier
serum from their secret stash
say that 10 times fast she wants to use
it to empower more people for their
fight
nico was a fan of the old captain
america and compares what he did in the
past
to what carly is doing now giving people
hope
it's a comparison carly's kind of not
down with as she hates what the
symbolism of cap stands for and thinks
that shield should be destroyed
this my friends is a bit of
foreshadowing and pays off in a brutal
way
later on in the episode sam bucky and
zemo figure that they can meet up with
carly at dania's vigil to talk it out
just when a plan is coming together john
walker shows up to potentially ruin the
entire thing wait
did i say potentially no dude actually
just ruined it i agree
with your fight i just can't give it the
way you're fighting it
and i'm sure she wouldn't either carly
morgan thought you're under arrest
so this is what that was no carlos
tricked me into your bucket right this
is why no one likes you john
you see while sam understands carly's
fight and wants to bring it to a
peaceful conclusion the new cap can't
quite wrap his head around that idea
just wants to crap on everything carly
gets away in the ensuing scuffle but not
before being shot by zemo and dropping
what's left of the serum which the mo
promptly river dances all over save for
one vial that john walker sneakily
sneaks into his patriotic cargo pants
back at the base john busts in to get
zemo and starts a fight because he just
can't help himself and then the door
melange bust in coming for zema as well
and basically take out everybody the
door milaje don't have jurisdiction here
the dora milaji have jurisdiction
wherever the dora milaje find
themselves to be also can we talk about
this storytelling moment here
ayo does what she has to do bucky can't
believe it's happening it's emotional
connection during the fight scene
and i love it shakti got his ass handed
to him by non-super soldiers john talks
to lamar about his frustrations and
insecurities
over the role he's been given with being
a super soldier
just make everything better power just
makes a person
more themselves right
carly morgenthau steve rogers
and me this pep talk from lamar echoes
what dr erskine told steve rogers way
back in the first captain america movie
about how the serum works
good becomes great bad becomes worse
this is why you've
chosen because a strong man
who has known power all his life may
lose respect for that power
but a weak man knows a value of strength
and knows compassion while john is
formulating a plan carly makes moves of
her own
calling sam's sister sarah threatening
her to get a meeting with sam
this all leads up to the climactic
battle of the episode jon has clearly
taken the serum to fight the flag
smashers
but is still overpowered by them in her
attempt to kill john carly
accidentally kills lamar instead jon
snaps
and in retaliation he brutally kills
nikko using captain america's shield
the symbol of freedom that both sam and
bucky cherish now covered
in blood this happens out in the open as
people are watching and streaming the
murder for the world to see
episode four got dark y'all i don't know
about you
but i could go for a little bit of that
zemo dancing right about now
honestly though i love how this show
continues to explore the complicated
idea
of who the heroes actually are and the
big problems with the power structures
in the world
there are only two episodes left do you
think we're gonna show down with the
power broker before it's all said and
done
who else from wakanda will make an
appearance and will sharon finally stop
doing favors for sam and bucky
let's talk about in the comments below
i'm carlos bustamante and i'll see you
next time
you